citizens of the reject Nation we are here
for the final episode of season three of The
Witcher Volume 2 Henry cavill's last hurray
as Gary Rivers the titular Witcher Greg how
you feeling I'm good John I'm excited for
uh Henry Cavill to hopefully get proper residuals
off of this while Netflix is raking in all
that dough you know before they take it off
the streaming service entirely never show
it to anyone ever again but anyway guys so
that that doesn't happen why don't you leave
a like on this video to let people know that
you're enjoying this as well subscribe to
the channel hit the notification Bell and
uh Greg you haven't you've got a message for
us today don't you oh yes we have a sponsor
that I I want to shout out can you leave for
a second I I would be honored my feathered
rejects today I've got a tail waggingly good
Scoop for you let's talk about our sponsor
bird dogs I'm wearing their uncomfortable
pants right now but I'll so they have their
shorts that'll have you looking fetching these
shorts are no bird brainers my friends let
me show you they're designed to fit Slimmer
through the thigh and the leg giving you a
truly possum sculpted look they do everything
Lululemon does but with an extra wag in their
tail so say goodbye to those rough cotton
shorts bird dogs fix that Mudder by creating
their Cloud knit fabric I mean come on it
looks as sharp as khaki but stretches like
a dog chasing its tail you're just gonna waste
them or fit without being you know leash stricted
got these puns going people here's the cherry
on top or should I say the bird on the wire
when you order from bird dogs.com using my
special code rejects you'll fetch a free Yeti
style tumbler it's the perfect companion for
hydrating on your adventures
Grandpa's medicine so don't sit on the perch
my pals hurry over to birddogs.com rejects
to unleash the possum power of these shorts
and snag your free Yeti style Tumblr trust
me once you experience the comfort and style
you'll be barking about bird dogs to all your
buddies they really are comfortable and a
lot of people want to know what are some of
the best ways to support the channel one of
the best ways to get yourself some bird dogs
by getting your tail wagon head to birddogs.com
rejects now
you're awake no news of nilfgaard or the girl
and no I didn't ask that's the wrong question
they will string you up and then how would
we have these lovely daily chats
it's like you want to leave the show we're
going to give you no lines we're going to
paralyze you out of the show you're sure this
one deserves your help let us decide that
same as we decided for you and the square
Hotel you've asked us to take in backstory
I will never command you milva nor return
you to the horrors of your past backstory
but you do owe a debt backstory
[Laughter] oh
[Applause] yeah
this looks kind of soothing honestly like
a good burn I hope you guys start working
on his back soon I know seems like the priority
number one can we even hold the damn sword
are you gonna stop him I've been telling him
for months he needs to think about himself
and not just Siri oh so you're not completely
useless but I was wrong what does he use to
get his chest hair that Perfect Trim you really
think you're ready to go find a girl [Music]
because you'd be dead now give him the ten
rings two years later [Laughter] geralt completes
physical therapy [Music] please
infesting the wolf a series siding with nilf
God we're obliged to join you'd fight for
Neil Scott no not you guys I love you guys
you guys are the best
you know where this villager Force has got
us toad track him with your magic what happened
here
Evans he'll take all of us to reverse the
spell they deserve that truly witchcraftian
for a show that actually has witches yeah
actually it feels like a like real witch
same page
these alliances are always fluctuating I feel
like they secretly just like it like that
it would get boring otherwise
vilkaforts did it under your nose yes anyone
who brought them here if she had looked after
them properly at our Tusa but with vilga forts
he simply propped up the mask save your sanctimony
stop I lost my hair in the process when are
we gonna remember my my brown locks my Auburn
locks you destroyed whomever just so that
visit me would finally see you lurking in
dextra's Shadows we are partners and I can
trust yeah like I trusted vilgaforts I love
how vilga forces suddenly like the big bang
he's like the king man we've been building
through this whole time friggin vilga forts
I liked old vilga Forks I'm counting every
minute Henry cavill's not on don't worry it's
gonna make every minute he is that much sweeter
your rival in aratuza helps secure what some
may call a victory it did I got these bottles
for that you made someone someone who knows
Andrea from the inside someone who has no
of God's interests at heart so you're proposing
that I forgive your past sins and return you
to syndra yes yes I mean you did it for kahir
as Imperial governor of centria and Francesca
can give her people the home they deserve
I must say from Jill and death it becomes
you
and thank you for recognizing that we delivered
what was promised the square Hotel deserve
peace no
the school you tell they stay with us they
know the lads so well they are an effective
force in the north you mean a dispensable
one son of a [__] kill him either they
die fighting for us or all of you people's
eye fighting to survive I'd follow this guy
anywhere yeah he really seems enlightened
man he's different he's like a Netflix CEO
Dara tuser is a pile of rocks the Brotherhood
has no brothers left and my brother's dead
enough ditch somewhere not you sickest man
oh that our intelligence was right and our
plan was correct none of which stops my people
from doubting me examples must be made we're
not friends anymore oh what's going to happen
to him I'm gonna execute him I know how much
you like Philippa but someone's got to pay
ah that'll drive her back toward her sister's
here on thin ice Geeks [Music] lover ah perfectly
eavesdropping the symbolism
cool music yeah I start whipping that sword
around sure you still got it should he still
got it geralt
[Music]
training is fixing all of his injuries [Music]
he does do a good job selling the pain and
the anger and frustration there's like some
Dark Knight Rises flares to this awesome War
evil overtaking while our hero is healing
his back
leg every day that I spend air is another
that's serious in danger because you're hiding
from the world doesn't mean that I have to
no uh tough out hurt there for her man she's
like the only Asian person in this world no
it's lonely
[Applause] I'm not scared to leave oh I'm
scared of what I do to them what you do sounds
necessary does it remind you of someone you
lost it looks important it reminds me of someone
I killed well we go way back yeah whatever
that did to you I hope they pay what if she's
in the wrong Daryl hahaha what if she's just
crazy context is so important yeah we haven't
heard all sides of the story you could have
handed series head over to the Kings on a
platter to win support but you didn't motherly
instincts your pain is my pay codependency
that's what John and I say to each other before
we read comments
feeling sorry for yourself and I think vocal
thoughts make you question who you are I know
you at your core the monolith inside you everything
that's been done to me I've survived because
of your faith you are the strongest force
I've ever known Archer core you are a beautiful
brunette woman you ought to say a debris you
are a mother we need you I need you
found you some hair dye the service for the
novices it's time
thank you wow you too the acting is still
so good that the the editing of the scenes
just goes so fast yeah hey we got [__]
to do man it's the end of the season there
is a cost to this magic and eventually we
all must pay it is not a gift it is a trade
you have to wield it a little bit and that
trade leads us to Dark Places yeah that's
a good look on her yeah she's getting off
the weight now you has been the biggest Bright
Spot Of My Life I know you will do great things
my daughter where is this going she can suffer
something thank you
sometimes a flower [Music] flower flower another
call back bringing an awful Circle and the
thing it can do for us is dying
to say a no [Music] oh whoa what [Music]
who's gonna watch her bird now that's tragic
moments before it was a very rousing empowering
speech that Jennifer was giving yeah because
it didn't work yeah I want to let her be my
motivational speaker track record is not serving
you well
it's my fault and let me feed me
did your best man [Music] I'm so hungry [Music]
who do we have now you have each other I will
find Siri why is my just can't do this without
care hey they're more unified than ever
oh the thoughts pay I'll make a mirror pay
too [Music] this might look a little different
but I wonder if in the healing process it's
gonna like cause some type of regeneration
thingy yeah I feel like that's the the easiest
magical explanation yeah like he's not gonna
fully heal now [Music]
promised a seamless transition I don't know
someone's got to pay
oh who's it gonna be Gods is true you're here
you're alive
I'm a homosexual brother I'm coming out I
found me and helped get me hurt your highness
I could not rest until I knew he was safe
he created a power vacuum in the Brotherhood
only we can feel the Brotherhood is in shambles
in the north with it yes well I have a new
plan for redania I love the guy who plays
the king yeah I think he's so good is a perfectly
thankless role well I was coming to ask you
to uh let me go go where in case you haven't
noticed there's a war going on and I'm no
helping it you'd be you've been trying for
years to find a purpose for me here oh no
he's found a purpose finally found something
that suits me someone and he needs my help
he was there to say I'm a homosexual pretty
much I just need to go be me visit me he's
not wrong
the only demands accountability [Music] you
can't pull this off in this state man you
got magic man he's gonna just do it to himself
I think just television here it was my fault
I knew I could trust you with my life oh I've
made plans to protect us both
yeah no all right
I was just saying
seems like the cleaning house and I'm just
thinking when it gets suspense beat with dijkstra
but I'll I'll trade him for the game I'm gonna
take a mirror I'm Jessica you can't take a
deal from a plan that was never real it could
work bars what is with these holy grounds
and these excessive amount of candles it must
be so hot
all humans are brutal he's a liar do you know
the Hedgehog may be killed and then you try
to set me up for it and I kind of took credit
but I didn't actually do it and then he keeps
rodania try to manipulate you our child and
you knew
uh Amir was coming to sintra and I had to
gain his favor and so I told him that your
baby your baby was gone there's a way of keeping
you here keep us fighting I can't undo what
I've done let's get oh yeah deserves to suffer
just as you have you do not get to cry I don't
this will be the Oscar clip the Emmy clip
he does not know the meaning of suffering
but he will and so will you yeah Boogie oh
my God it only took the last like 20 minutes
of season three to finally care about her
things are really cooking now G it's gonna
be a great last Act of the episode
you're the king now radovid oh the brother
will suspect how did this happen oh God we'll
find out whoever is responsible will be made
to pay we must move quickly our enemies will
capitalize on this tragedy say we are leaderless
she changed her hair fast I know she's got
so many great Styles it's our great Fortune
radovid is back safely Mighty of heart and
spirit yep take it Long Live King you know
there's a time and a place yeah I know maybe
not right in front of the Dead bro Over My
Dead Body [Music]
and and bummer about King vismir really poor
timing maybe she was sleeping with that girl
just to use her yeah I brought us back here
to make good on the promise of never letting
the Salvation our Chooser is gone the future
of magic has never been more unstable but
it lies in your hands Sisterhood rise the
most dangerous Mage we've ever seen has the
most powerful Source this continent has ever
known we need to eliminate vocaforts yes we
know God I feel like they've been essentially
repeating just in different lines yeah a little
bit but in different places the subject and
with different people now dead it's all the
same never interrupt an artist when he is
in a state of numinous flow
oh my god when I found my own people I thought
I'd recovered what I'd lost but they agreed
to help the White Flame start at War so I
ran and so far [Music] too Brooklyn Forest
this hatred it'll kill me yes it will oh after
being off screen for 15 minutes he's back
she was the first person that I ever felt
safe with tell her I forgive her and that
I'm sorry good good I've been waiting for
that hey I'll be excited for his Redemption
don't worry itching for that I'm in your corner
Dara everyone being as powerfulness [Music]
pretty cool one more girl chemistry sequences
yeah man-made yes girl YouTube mate we have
to cook foreign [Music]
[Music]
[Music] [Applause]
you'd be dead now
bring the Cajun girl with you yeah the one
with the backstory who owes you some stuff
yeah Nova subplot [Applause]
[Music] roll music yeah we're gonna get like
a heavy version of one of you ask your songs
for the end credits Henry cavill's barely
been in these last three episodes this episode
series barely fitted it's as if he already
left an auspicious day my Lord whoa what happened
to your face my friend build a face get it
have you heard of an eye patch vilga Fury
is hereby endowed with the title of Duchess
of Rowan and himla oh there's going to be
a scene of like come with me Siri yeah but
is it a real Siri or is it another fake Siri
welcome home you know where you belong
it's a pleasure Your Grace I thought Liam
Hemsworth was going to come to this show what's
going on baby they're changing everyone big
switch
oh boy wait is she the same one from the few
episodes ago who thought she was Siri I think
it's a different one but I'm not 100 I know
we've seen that girl before I just don't remember
which one nice to see you finally awake you
want to get out of here yeah [Laughter]
she's been here before Haley heard of him
one of the rats at the barn the rats they
are rats oh wow that's the wind enough God's
been searching for you're as useless as a
unicorn she's not more than more than what's
between her legs the way you think this is
what's happening inside the buildings on Pirates
of the Caribbean I like that shot of Siri
studying how he was listening to see if he's
like tempted At All by this information
this [__] is Highborn oh there it is yeah
jump on it she told you she was hungry kid
this guy's cool the rat is mine touch him
again I'll plunge this blade Through Your
Eyes the rat's in the white wolf you get it
show me show me boys come on how did she get
it
the rats these are the rats the Rat Pack
[Applause] turning up that frame rate I knew
you were alive you little [__] obviously
done okay
these cool Street rats man yeah I'm excited
to spend the last five minutes with us yeah
that's a cool swashbuckling vibe to them I
like it yeah
cool they know how to throw down on a fight
boy
oh nice
hey trouble make it double how about a fair
fire
kick his ass sea bass prove you're worth Siri
let's see how you do against a human [Music]
so my daddy girl taught you you're finally
with people your own age join the ravagers
Gamora oh she's gonna do this like one one
hit she's gonna be one slice she's gonna like
bisect him up the center
she's playing with him
[Music] whoa yeah good job kid I will say
this this season really has drastically made
me care more about Siri I'm way more interested
in her development and how she's coming to
her own a lot more I think her even that last
episode I think really added to it yeah no
she's like the most intriguing part down yeah
I know she has set up the character she's
my she's the most one I'm most into when we
cut to her that's got to be another way around
not for days take this good man on you go
quid pro quo you want to get through your
pay
that looks nice hold on uh for your troubles
oh is that in the past go we were wandering
through boundless Fields towards an obelisk
curve with names of the Dead a woman with
cold blue eyes who's following you don't make
a difference geralt
Carol we need to get to Siri just keep witching
geralt
why don't you let the girl in her family go
face off or maybe I'll take her home and see
what you she can be put to not dude you're
just saying the worst things to finally be
afraid yeah geralt you'd always been afraid
until now because she's taking everything
from you great shot so taking the fear you're
ouch these Hot Head angles
neutrality be damned we are no longer afraid
goddamn right take on the whole Army's worth
whole battalion
there's some Henry Cavill for you
oh gnarly [Music] him oh my God finally
bitching you'd be dead
I know I'll be dead now missed one no I didn't
Save The Best For Last oh yeah that's why
I just punched you in the face you managed
to get to know God before I do you too come
here
I will free Siri oh he is declaring daddy
girl man family is the true Elixir we have
a side quest [Music]
Now give me coins so you can pass yeah I'm
still gonna pay this guy and I will make sure
this is safe world for her to return to [Music]
still left it behind yeah is this like a Celtic
House of the Rising Sun but we will be the
last to fall all my love [Music] cool is it
about to end it feels like it's about to end
with them just riding off into the next adventure
no transition in sight we gotta go is she
alone she can use a sword what's your name
join the rats come on I'm a rat call me falcon
[Music]
[Music] new song
you gotta be [__] kidding me that is the
final episode for Henry Cavill apparently
that's that's what I'm told that's what we
have been told that is [__] that is very
strange that is [__] it feels nothing
at all like there's about to be a major casting
change nah man this just reeks of behind the
scenes troubles yeah yeah it really does every
rumor I've heard I feel like is true now man
God they didn't even like give a [__]
to make it a send-off that is not a send-off
that's the promise he's barely in this episode
he's barely I mean he's like obviously barely
in the last one too oh man this is this is
the direction I promise of more geralt yaskir
and milva Adventures like it's it's not a
bad episode I I don't think it's a bad episode
I don't think it's like flawless I don't think
it it's fantastic or anything but there's
definitely things I really liked about this
episode
okay but then you do got to separate the context
of this is also Henry cavill's last episode
uh as geralt and just knowing how absent he
was from the screen time in the last three
episodes and they still use him as the main
advertisement he is still the titular character
yeah he's The Witcher oh boy I maybe maybe
it was an attempt to go he's not returning
so we really got to put focus on these other
plot lines that way the audience is really
invested in in you know these other storylines
that they'll want to return for season four
but you know that's not where people's heads
are at right now come on come on I know there
are people obviously there are people who
love all the story lines who are very much
have their hearts vested into all these other
ones of course of course everyone is also
very much well aware and it also kind of just
you know speaks a little bit towards that
fact of how uh out of touch the writer the
the show Runners uh have been with uh the
audience so you know I think regardless of
whatever [__] you got with Henry Cavill
I'm like you got to be of service in this
moment man this is a terrible send-off this
is not even remotely close what do you think
we're just gonna walk in like acting like
business as usual next season and be like
all of a sudden yeah did you shoot something
else with Henry Cavill That You're Gonna Save
till the beginning of next season for some
kind of sequence that directly explains this
or is he just gonna show back up as Liam Hemsworth
and you're just gonna is the seamless transition
just that we will never acknowledge it and
we're just going to keep going as if nothing
happened yeah barely a scene with yennefer
no scene with Siri no no yeah no real proper
send-off oh God is I feel like I could just
kind of lament my emotions about that this
entire time not even talk about anything else
that happened I mean yeah because there's
a lot that happened there but God damn that
is [__] it is [__] it is this episode
has two responsibilities it has the sending
off of Henry Cavill as geralt and then everything
else you know yeah I think with the send-off
what they were attempting to do was tie it
back into the first episode of you know geralt
where you know we obviously had Henry Cavill
there him literally leaving uh the the approach
thing yeah whatever that is behind uh as symbolic
of saying goodbye to the past with with this
with this version of geralt I feel like that
was the attempt to do that sure not enough
so it's so minimal it is such a small it's
it it and uh it's not even a line between
subtle and Grand you know it is no it's just
like a nice thematic thing I'm glad they paid
attention to but like as the rest of it postures
as if it is just business as usual and that
he did just recover and is gonna be you know
out upon many more an adventure or whatever
oh God man because they really they've really
really diminished his screen time well yeah
obnoxiously barely yeah it is very strange
and whenever he is on screen most of the dialogue
comes back to the same stuff about like oh
you just all about your family man that family
is really giving you a lot of a lot of reason
to live man oh hey your family's in danger
you gotta go fight for her we'll we'll get
back together you gotta go find Siri find
Siri geralt Siri geralt Siri like I don't
know I it's that was so awful part of me was
more open to the idea of what it looked I
I made peace at a certain point in the episode
I was like okay so maybe we won't get him
back kicking ass like we did at one point
but maybe yeah they'll do something where
this healing process is painful and will have
some kind of character thing that needs to
be let go of and in that process he will transform
in this regeneration into Liam Hemsworth and
like part of me was like okay if they're gonna
commit to that then fine I could be open to
that but then they I kind of like give you
your cake in an attempt to let you eat it
too because then he comes back and he does
the whole badass like I'm making my own potion
thing and then he like levels that whole Battalion
of of uh you know soldiers and whatnot and
it's like they give you like one last badass
fight to like I feel like who cares at this
voice fight scene well yeah it's like they
gave you a bunch of stuff but none of which
like coalesce or harmonize with each other
they feel like disjointed and stuff and so
yeah like it's it's such a strange his Arc
has already been well established yeah of
of who he has art into he's a family man that's
all he is he is I get it like yeah I don't
want to harp The Fast and Furious forever
but it does feel like they did kind of mimify
that part of the character or at least just
rest most everything on that yeah he's become
a softy yeah I like you yaskir you're my best
friend Jennifer I love you and Siri I'm a
Daddy to you and I get kick ass once in a
while when I have to I don't like anybody
else so when anybody else around I could kick
ass sometimes but yeah maybe they did shoot
something additional for them to use or they're
just going to cut to us Liam Hemsworth um
but okay uh I I think that geralt's storyline
here uh while personal for the most part for
the entirety of the Season uh I I I did love
how he like like my favorite moments where
geralt are still the end of volume
my mind actually flashes too when he just
lets it out to yennefer that he loves her
that felt like yeah yeah that felt like the
climax of his character yeah that to me that
was complete there and then here I guess is
the pie um so yeah okay there's that God I
I am so like how can I just focus on the episode
now okay that is such a that is such crap
well I was getting so worried when I was I
was just getting so worried we're they would
cut to him for like a minute and then they'd
be gone for 10 minutes then he's back for
a minute then he's gone for like 10 minutes
again yeah it was that was just the structure
of this episode that is uh that that is that
is this really bothersome man that really
bothers me yeah it's odd it no it just it
is awesome
like he really is it seems like so so on it's
such a weird thing to have an actor so embroiled
in this kind of situation across so many different
planes of of entertainment yeah and uh yeah
I don't know it is one of those things I think
you're right that just does when you see it
make you wonder because they've been talking
about it you know in the lead up to the season
no no it's gonna make sense it's gonna be
totally smooth and they know people are they
obviously know this on everybody's mind everyone's
anticipating this and so uh they I don't know
just the promise of more like it ends on the
promise of more it ends in the promise of
of uh of her from Shang Chi and him and yaski
are going out on more Adventures yeah and
even their like Bromance over this as you
know not been as engaged or whatever I don't
know um all right well I think we've made
it really clear how we feel there so good
send off loved Henry oh man um and I mean
I don't know honestly I just don't care enough
to return to this show I I just don't like
I I I my interest in most of these story lines
just has felt like diminishing returns the
more this goes on I I care about very few
things in in this show now it's not even just
the Henry cow it's really not the Henry Cavill
thing well I I think we can talk about the
things that I that we did like um I mean I
don't know if you like more than me but we'll
see I really I really like what they've developed
with Siri that's been my biggest takeaway
yeah uh out of what they did to Henry Cavill
my biggest takeaway is before it was like
just you know Henry Cavill yennefer and Siri
was always an important part of the story
and I always cared about the interactions
that others would have off like the the importance
of her storyline but Siri the character she's
never been a bad eye for never remembering
the actress's name I've never thought that
uh and I know if some people really love her
her storyline I love her and like while I've
always thought she was good I just never personally
really gravitated towards her character so
much as a Solo character to be watching and
with the last episode and then this one she's
on her own she's away from the main story
lines you know as her story is developing
and I'm sure there's some wonderful Easter
egg there with that name drop that she decides
to go by oh yeah do you know I have no idea
what the hell it is we didn't read the books
play the game so I don't know significant
that's
amazing uh cool and I really do love how they've
developed her character because yeah when
they do cut to her very late into the episode
and she's tied up and everything and just
like the the performance that she carries
in her eyes as she's tied up it did hit me
right in that moment like oh [__] I really
love what they've done with her she's like
I I noticed like I really want to be here
right now with her I'm not thinking about
anything else I'm not thinking about cut to
anything else I'm really interested right
now in what's going on because it's her yeah
so that was a big Telltale sign to me of okay
I love what they've done with her 100 that's
grown to me that's grown really nicely because
at the beginning of the show I was in a similar
position to you where I was like yeah this
stuff is interesting enough when it's on screen
I'm not super invested in Syria and what her
Stakes are one way or the other however just
the more yeah she has been developed through
her bonding with geralt and Yen and all that
stuff and yeah and come into her own and such
and her you know just acting has grown you
know as she has grown on this and I think
in some ways it's nicest pitched to capture
a lot of magic with her because she's coming
of age in real life as this character is also
coming of age uh and so yeah like I I think
they've made that stuff some of the most interesting
I actually care about her Stakes the the weird
intersection of everyone's need to use her
for some purpose or that means to her her
you know aspirations of being a Witcher and
a Mage and all that stuff like that's actually
like quite like if I was compelled to return
it would be to find out mostly about her journey
because yeah she doesn't feel like I think
successfully she feels like a propulsive and
engaged part of the story whereas certain
characters who I really like feel like perfunctory
characters that they're trying to keep around
yeah um but yeah and I think her performances
are really great and I liked her action scene
there at the end a lot uh and her you know
portrayal of of just the weird struggle of
like all these harsh things she's having to
do and even though we've dogged on her over
the season for you know the times when it's
like lay low Siri and she's like going out
and causing a ruckus or whatever like I've
always been yeah pretty compelled by and enjoying
watching her yeah uh and I feel like of all
of our main characters hers is the most substantively
written storyline Jennifer I always have loved
uh I I've always loved Jennifer and you know
the actress um oh my God
alotra she's amazing regardless I think uh
she's she's amazing and I I really love I
I just love the aura and the vibe of the witches
uh when they really feel like witches yes
you know the my favorite Parts is the convent
is that the word fruit Covenant Covenant guy
keep saying the wrong uh Covenant Kevin yeah
forgive me guys cousin of witches um sleep
schedule way off words vocabulary even more
diminishing before the full moon um yeah but
yeah when they're in procession and they've
got the candles and they're chanting and they're
really forming like a a real cover like it's
been a Brotherhood it's been a Brotherhood
of sorcerers for a long time with like a lot
of female Mages that's never felt like witches
it's never truly felt like witchcraft yeah
so now having this like Sisterhood they haven't
named it that but you know what appears to
be that arising does give it this like really
fun cool yeah especially witchy Druid like
aesthetic and I I really love that and while
I think the aesthetic was very appealing and
the the capturing of the whole mood was appealing
I did feel like the scenes in and of themselves
were always like get your [__] together
we gotta kill vilgavors yeah we're all suffering
and we're all grieving and we're all just
sort of like hey can't we just get it together
ah you know yeah we got I thought every scene
ended with we're gonna rise up but another
time they cut back to them they're they're
sad and it ends with we gotta rise up yeah
I thought before it's just getting closer
that we did this yeah yeah totally um so yeah
I thought the writing of that in particular
was not the strongest the the the uh stuff
um I'm still kind of processing that in a
better episode I think this that could have
been handled like the choice for what happens
with their character totally makes sense uh
and and it does show just how how destroyed
because she's like the leader you know and
how destroyed everything really is and how
does Sheila Fordson so close and well it shows
the hopelessness of their situation yeah but
yet I don't really feel the hopelessness of
their situation because this show is asking
me to care about a billion different story
lines well it's right and like you pointed
out the editing like it does feel like it's
chop chopping its way along like yes it should
have been happening in a better story should
have happened in a better episode you know
because it's like it's one of many billion
things that happened in this one episode well
this feels like a season that could be like
10 episodes if you're really gonna do all
this off sending and and stuff like that I
don't know yeah five and three I get it for
where they split the story it makes sense
but at the same time I don't know there's
just yeah a lot that they could have like
the this episode was packed with a lot of
stuff but the problem is that it highlights
the time you're spending away from Henry Cavill
and it could have been better proportion maybe
in other ways but yeah but yeah the hopping
uh from all that and then you have like all
this stuff with like dijkstra and Philippa
and rodania yeah oh God yeah uh the king who
like I like the king I like the king's performance
when he was with the brother I was like you
know I love the brother I think he's been
a great addition to the show yeah he's been
terrific I think he's been yeah that's something
the turn with him is intriguing I I thought
he's been consistently really appealing to
watch and the king I really like too he feels
very natural he's got just the right amount
to feel like arrogant pompous guy who's in
a royalty position kind of dumb but also you
can see how he takes command you know like
I really liked when he's with terrible names
what does he specifically say to him don't
handle me or something like that yeah like
I know what you're trying to like the way
he says that you know like oh he shows that
he is he's smart know what you do to me a
lot of the time yeah yeah what your job is
and that you're good at it yeah at the end
of the day he is smart and you see how he
is a king despite how sniveling he is and
I really I think his his acting is just so
good so it bummed me out when he died because
he brings such life to that character and
it's yeah it's a hard one to do without being
a complete cartoon yes I really liked him
so it bummed me out when he when he died um
character
I don't know I mean the show sheep's trying
to tell me he's like really smart but he just
seems like progressively weak as as a character
as he keeps going yeah and I mean maybe I
gotta go back and re-watch but it just didn't
feel like the whole you wanna I think feel
with that character like what he says is kind
of true that like yes there's a certain element
of luck involved with all of our machinations
and even though it didn't go in our favor
this time we still got some type of benefit
out of the situation it does kind of feel
like hey you had a vague plan and you walked
in and uh hit the fan yeah yeah and you shot
your your shot but uh you know the fact that
he gave him one more chance I was like he
could easily just been like no like we've
you've cost me too much now we're done here
yeah that was a bummer I mean it's like it's
cool for uh Philippa I think her name is like
it's cool for her dynamic because she's really
the one pulling all the strings yeah but yeah
um I guess uh uh visit me wasn't so smart
after all I gotta tell you man uh I think
one of the most disappointing parts of this
season is everything to do with white flame
um that dude is just not as interesting as
the season finale set him up to be well he's
just always like chilling at the Capitol like
in his you know Chambers just like giving
people Redemption and sending them out on
missions it's all the all the scenes they've
given him have not felt in anything unique
they feel as generic and by the numbers as
you'd expect when you have such an interesting
setup for this guy with with knowing his introduction
knowing his backstory well they're giving
him like the bad guy treatment when I feel
like we could be really spending time watching
this guy Rule and getting like a complicated
portrait of what his you know real out in
the open Agenda is yeah I don't I don't care
about him uh that is such a great Cliffhanger
with him in the last season and then here
they have made the interest level on him just
go down so much uh boring and uh that we did
not see kahir thank God never really liked
him um uh I like you okay I fell for uh uh
frangela and Francesca is that her name the
elf lady I I I like their ultimate ending
scene the scene most of the time I mean I
like fringeal for the most part I do um but
the elf lady yeah I'm like oh finally she
gets one true like I liked I liked her in
the battle when her brother died and all and
she looked cool and whatever when she's all
smeared in blood but her actual but she she's
only really to me got one good scene here
in the season where I'm like oh you're finally
an interesting character character yeah I'm
just yeah Warrior or whatever not just a symbol
well there are everyone's just given just
that I think the dialogue has gone so downhill
well yeah I mean yeah it's felt very repetitive
in certain aspects and then other aspects
they just pull in I don't know it's weird
like the language the voice of the show to
my ear has changed each season and this feels
the least sort of immersed in what I associate
with I don't know that first impression of
season one feeling a bit more again I keep
coming back to the phrase literary the term
literary because it used to feel like this
was ripped out of a book and now it feels
like a cool action you know fantasy thing
this feels like Wikipedia the movie sure sure
yeah yeah yeah no exactly because that's about
as much meat as you get on a lot of these
characters or or not even Wikipedia it's like
every episode is a Wikipedia it's more it's
more close notes it's more akin to um reading
of fandom wire page where you you want to
know what happens in an episode yeah and that's
what a lot of it feels like uh it it would
would intermittently like a really compelling
scene that comes in the form of your interest
in the characters uh I kind of like archery
Asian lady from sunshi
I like her uh she's got Charisma so I I like
her and they were shows obviously we don't
have time to dive into your backstory so it
was just wonderful let's give some quick little
hints that we accepted you here you have an
origin where you lost stuff and you owe us
yeah we're gonna hold that over your head
forever more details to come yeah so I liked
her and I I did feel like the bummer part
of it and I made the joke early on the bummer
part of it is when it is yaskir and uh geralt
and her in the end I was like yeah they are
a good Trio I I like them I like them as a
trio and now I gotta adjust my brain to Liam
Hemsworth if I want to watch the next season
but man I I I I I I I just don't care and
a lot of this stuff is like even when it comes
to the king who we liked even for the qualities
of the acting of dijkstra and the Mage and
the Mages even the Mages you know even there
I I I can everything we're talking about I
can appreciate I can definitely pinpoint things
to appreciate about it but if we're talking
about is my heart and soul truly uh invested
or can't give a [__] while watching it
to the point where I'm like emotionally enthralled
or pulled in to the degree where not one part
of me is checking out I'm not gonna lie to
you I'm totally like like I really got nothing
going on here but most of the times there's
really nothing happening in my heart uh for
for most of this it's not even Josiah's death
it's like oh bummer yeah because things move
I'm willing to move on right now let's get
a move on here because yeah we're being whisked
along to the next plot line yeah yeah it's
it's a bummer because I feel like this show
and especially the season to me is marked
by again all the potential that's like here
on screen there's so much that they have working
for them and I think spending time in this
world is really fun the sets and the effects
that bring the world to life or for the most
part beautiful to look at oh sorry hold there's
a lot of sweeping camera work and some definitely
fights Great Performances all that stuff costumes
everything but yeah experience of experiencing
the story just feels like it's become increasingly
sort of like a mess and and yeah it's like
this has felt more sort of like uh yeah as
sort of not not quite like a blockbuster but
some sort of like fantasy light thing that
has all the production values that you want
but there's just yeah isn't going I don't
know it's just not making it feel like you're
living in this world as much as it used to
and it's also I don't know for me as a monster
fan kind of feel like it is really struggling
to maintain that aspect of the show which
like like which shirt that's way gone yeah
and I feel like The Witcher lifestyle The
Witcher vocation such as it is and what we've
seen about with like the fall of care morning
like like the state that that's in I feel
like there's lots you could do with the witchers
of the world they introduce so many different
storylines and then the story lines are continuing
or they're getting less and less interesting
it feels like they should have spread all
this over more seasons you know it's like
like this all feels like it should have been
happening at like season four or five or something
like that and then let you know this is weak
ass Cliffhanger I gotta say this is a terrible
Cliffhanger well no it it's weird it feels
like I get why they split this chunk the way
it did but the overall season feels like it
is the first half of something yeah I think
the Cliffhanger is like what was the Cliffhanger
last one wild Hunt oh [__] wild Hunt is
on and here is Dooney yeah yeah um yeah and
the wild hunters barely a smoking topic of
conversation here like and like that was at
least wow it was gonna be crazy next season
and and it'd be nice maybe the name she drops
has something to do with it because she's
embracing chaos magic that's a guess I have
no idea I'm sure I could Google it I'll find
out but uh this this Cliffhanger like while
I love uh everything they have done with Siri
and while I feel like she's become out of
all the characters she's become my favorite
yeah of them all yeah I I I still I'm like
well yeah I mean you've you've essentially
got her further away from the main plot now
that she's off with these guys I mean they'll
take their time more in the future like it's
weird I am excited like that was a cool Prospect
I'm like yeah these I like the first guy that
they introduce you to and then seeing them
all fight you know the tavern full of guys
like yeah I was like cool well I'll see Siri
like travel around with these dudes for a
while before you know getting anywhere near
the Emir plot again but you need like a strong
central core Focus it's family you need a
strong central core Focus if you look at many
of our greatest um which I you know would
be that they want Siri and we gotta beat nilfgaard
right yeah but for some reason it still feels
so messy it still feels all over the place
but if you look at like our great fantasy
films you know the Harry Potter movies uh
Lord of the Rings like Lord of the Rings is
a great example of it is it's like as many
storylines as many characters as you're cutting
around to in as much GI photography as you're
going around to it's all centering back to
Sauron in the ring and you got to make sure
he doesn't get that ring you know that he's
Rising that it's like a real simple you need
that you need that simple thing to centralize
and ground the comp the complicated aspects
well because that'll yeah and that is not
really great it's like yeah I can say it nilfgaard
White Flame you know but for some reason I'm
like I still feel like this is all over the
place I still feel like I need to go wait
wait hold on can I get this all on like a
piece of paper in front of me so that I can
fill in the blanks for myself yeah you need
a strong central Focus that you could always
come back to to keep everything like zeroed
in to keep it from becoming chaos it feels
a little bit like chaos now and it's like
you need that strong central point so that
you can both delve out the plot points when
you need to and do Exposition but also so
that you can sell just living and traveling
and feel feeling the actual you know it's
a time very much removed from now and I think
it's important in these things to show that
and I think especially in these later like
this season certainly doesn't feel like it
takes much time to get anywhere or like there's
any much distance between things really or
even when Game of Thrones was great you know
they would be all over the place there would
be a lot to keep up with it would be totally
like so much and it wasn't as a simplified
Focus they would kind of have a simple focus
of like who's the main you know computer hierarchy
so you've got you know there's lots of unrested
between the houses the Lannisters are your
big big problem and then you've got the white
walkers over here that's like your problem
outside of everything and they're building
to that and they did a great job per season
as establishing what the per storyline what
the main things were to focus and worry about
from protagonist antagonist you know so I
and I think that this this just doesn't have
that it it is it's just a big zigzag yeah
of of like man they keep changing up these
plots and then even even like with the brother
becoming King like oh I I don't even it's
all happening so fast everything's just has
Tumbleweed and you'll have certain episodes
too where it's like you'll be hopping around
a lot and then you'll take a break and you'll
do like an interlude where it's like way slower
than everything else and and like that last
episode was just like mostly in the desert
yeah and I'm like this is cool but it's not
amounting to as much as this show-stopping
moment seems to think it like it would Merit
and I don't want to feel like every time Witcher
comes back I gotta re-watch all of Witcher
in order to like try to understand like what's
happening you know yeah and I think there
is something to be said for the fact that
like when these things are cooking you can
not get every last thing but get enough to
form strong associations so that hey if a
name is confusing at least you have like a
good idea of who's who when you see them and
what the you know major conflicts are and
I feel like yeah in a show this show has been
a lot more of like wait wait hold on I gotta
keep track of this stuff rather than like
they're helping me form those associations
emotionally yeah you know especially as we've
gotten deeper into this um anyway guys I did
not like this season oh yeah overall like
I like stuff about it obviously I think as
a whole I will remember this as the one that
made me go I don't think I want to watch this
show anymore um so yeah I and it is not have
anything to do with like standing for Henry
Cavill or something like that even though
I obviously vehemently and very much not satisfied
in any close capacity he's been great as this
character and especially these last three
episodes like not to say that he wasn't invested
but even his presences don't feel very punctuated
by much and he's been you know decommissioned
it feels like yeah the crescendo was when
they went to the ball together in the end
of the first volume of season three yeah so
as a season overall though I thought it was
very it had very minimal impact and it was
a bit of a a chore sometimes just keeping
my eyes on the screen um and so yeah while
there was things to appreciate for sure which
I we have covered uh I I overall I am I I
don't think I unless there's like just the
most insane word of mouth oh my God why did
they put Liam in to begin with unless there's
a craziest Word of Mouth uh I'm not making
plans right now to watch uh season four um
unless the Word of Mouth from audiences is
so good I'm looking more at like what our
audience is saying sure and unless that is
great um then yeah I I have no interest right
now uh and know that we declared this early
on before all you guys start coming at us
going why aren't you reacting to season four
wheelers
no rage watches yeah leave your thoughts Down
Below guys on what you guys thought of The
Witcher season three be very curious to know
um leave a like and thank you so much for
being here and we will talk with you all soon
but before we go let's shout out some patrons
Jacob Neptune I'd give him a left nut Christian
Neal I'd kneel before you Ryan Smith I'd poop
with the door closed for you Kevin Meek let's
let's go take a long walk on the beach Adrian
Tim's I'd let you have a fry real nagas you
can you can copy my math homework it's cool
Jonathan May uh I love your body nothing is
more clear than the greatness of Heather gear
I will never snitch on yui and Simon no matter
how horrible it gets for the last time Songhai
Glover it's okay you can just have my kidney
Kaylee King I don't know why we don't do karaoke
together more often I got a bone to pick with
you Alan Ling you know get over here we'll
settle this Logan your uh flies down see Kelsey
the key to a good fried egg is to cook it
slowly Cara someone broke into your car last
night and I did nothing when I saw it happen
ericon's 39 I can't wait to slather you in
baby oil no one said you were racist it just
it just sounded racist when you said it why
yes Nick X I do know how to change a tire
and I can show you as well hey Dijon if that's
the hill you want to die I'm so be it I mean
Kevin Spacey doesn't have as many supporters
these days Juan Longoria you're the Don Juana
my Demarco Cliff Rodriguez just submit your
script now no one's pitching them right now
Arturo Malian Higginbotham Jr oh my God I
I want to just live on your estate and be
your servant go Nation no one has to know
that I walked in on you touching yourself
so stop broadcasting it please Lorenzo Baxter
you dog you hey differently saying um did
you share my Max password with someone because
uh having a hard time logging in I swear Marco
Tunstall I'll get you the money I just need
a few more days it's coming all right give
me a chance all right Lauren the drop off
point it's gonna be right in front of the
Hooters
I like that store
simply faded nothing's ever that simple with
you but that's why I like you you're complex
sj94 if you didn't get tested how's anyone
supposed to know that it came from you Justin
Martin look you've had enough I'm cutting
you off now okay Rosie what you want to do
is find a home buy it and then you can rent
it out that way you can earn the equity over
the course of several years on your property
that's just good advice listen Colin you got
you gotta choose last name I know it's open-ended
and you like the options but come on man it's
time to pick one Philip Smith people are starting
to become suspicious of what the J stands
for I don't want to say what people think
the J stands for but it rhymes with coup
Jen Smith we need more of that Moxie around
here you got the job you're hired I think
the outfit was revealing Melody I think it
showed courage
certainly it did you are a brave brave soul
and all of you are all of you who support
us each month with your love and your enthusiasm
never stop never stopping guys thanks for
being the life's blood of the recheck Nation
the truest of the true citizens stay Pleasant
we'll catch you next month